here we go
all right
all right another day another vlog i'm
trying to do vlogs weekly right and you
know not the typical vlogs that you
always see because i'm always trying to
do something different but guess what
today was a glorious day so i have to
share something with y'all when i have
an amazing food experience and i think
that speaks for a lot of foodies out
there we just we just have to share it
and i'm telling you right now i think i
think i found
the best if not one of the best
pizzerias in los
the angeles makes the tomato taste like
beautiful hard nipple
listen i know what you're thinking what
what what did this asian guy know about
a pizza pie huh
was that italian or korean italian
people don't want you [ __ ] up their
food they're very serious about that
stuff passionate people i dare you to
put something stupid on a pizza pie
watch this hey a giuseppe i'm gonna put
a pineapple on a pizza pie
[Music]
no pineapple and look i get it that's
actually respectable to a certain point
because one thing that i really really
dislike especially in this new food
space with social media and everything
is when people misrepresent somebody
else's food and culture and i'll tell
you how they do this they do this by
creating the shittiest version of the
dish that represents you and your people
i don't understand why [ __ ] google
y'all for real can't just do this
but david that's just their version of
it motherfu i'm okay with that that's
fine just call your dish something else
or say that's inspired by it because
what happens is especially if you have a
following people's introduction of their
culture and their food comes from you
that's on you and by the way this isn't
gate keeping food because [ __ ] all that
stuff that's not what this is about
sometimes people bastardize the food you
grew up on and the stuff that you relate
to and love simply just because it'll
give them views and they don't think
twice about it and then you defend it
because they're not [ __ ] up your food
they're not misrepresenting your culture
but if the tables were turned you would
feel a certain way about it like i said
not gatekeeping [ __ ] make it at home do
whatever the [ __ ] you want with it serve
your friends but if you're gonna do an
instructional video and do a recipe on a
dish that you don't even know how to
[ __ ] make and on top of that it's
disgusting
shut it or not or i'm gonna come to your
house no i'll suck your face off dude
what's up you trying to get some of this
now having said that the piece of spot
that i'm about to show you is owned by
two of the most authentic
korean people ever what's up i don't
give a [ __ ] but on a serious note this
spot is actually owned by two korean
people and the joint is called pizzeria
in los angeles this place to me is a
representation of what i love about the
evolution of food when other people get
a hand on it and this is what i mean by
not gatekeeping food i was actually
introduced to pete city assay by my
buddy robin and pizza area say does
something very very interesting and the
style of pizza that they actually create
is called tokyo neapolitan for a lot of
people the differences can be subtle
like there's a salt punch that's added
to the oven right before the pie is
cooked but the thing that stands out the
most is this puffy slightly burnt crust
made from this super light dough look
when you eat this pizza you'll notice
right off jump how light and airy it is
and that charred crispy crust just makes
sense and by the way like a lot of great
things especially when it comes to food
the details are really really important
because it's even in the crust they fold
it a certain way right before throwing
in that hot hot oven that promotes that
blistering and char on the crust and
here's the thing this is why i love
tokyo neapolitan pizza and once again if
you don't keep food you really get to
see an evolution of it when somebody
takes the foundation of what already
makes a dish amazing and elevating it in
its own unique way so when we have this
conversation when it comes to food about
authenticity authenticity varies from
home to home because the way let's say
for example with korean food like the
way my mom made cream food isn't the way
that your mom probably would make it so
which one is more authentic i think what
happens when i talk about people who
misrepresent food is when somebody's not
even in the know or don't know anything
about the food or the ingredients and
they just throw things together and say
this is what it is i don't really like
that if i were to give you a few pro
tips before you go to pizza dsa i would
say go with about three people so you
can try three different individual
pizzas and then share each other's
slices so you could try a little bit of
everything and i like to get the
chardonnay because it has a little bit
acidity and crunch to that fatty fatty
cheese that you'll have with some of the
dishes there delicious enjoy my friends
spreading love and positivity to
everybody except for the people that i
hate you [ __ ] go die yeah suck
[Music]
you